il
le jour
comme dans un rêve
jean
besoin d'aidé
[Musique]
je suis un losange joaquim lavin côte
vous je retiens que physique je laisse
comme un mari martin non on l'a tous
fait chier six mois tu prends la main
pourquoi ma vie celle d'un porte je pars
faire emmerder pour deux encyclopédies
sur les cormorans jeu fabre de laval
s'apprend pas
[Musique]
alors hier soir il y avait top chef et y
en a un qui est très énervé c'est gilles
verdez qu'est ce qui se passe encore non
merde la merde dont j'ai pas regardé
mais la merde ya dix ans j'ai mal à ma
france sont prêtes à tout j'ai mal à ma
france et abily sans vraiment amer
qu'ils abattent
[Applaudissements]